what happened to his career after that
has he been in anything the Scott
Pilgrim he was good enough oh he was a
bit part I mean do you think that that
was detrimental for for him to be in
such a big role and then for it not to
do what worst one to ever
yeah I know cuz he was a no-name at that
point she auditioned again I think in
the new one oh he did Henry Cavill did
it
oh Henry Cavill is just amazing there's
certain guys that get [ __ ] and I don't
know what it is I mean you look at
somebody like Ralph Macchio yeah huge he
was a huge eighty star he was an iconic
movie Karate Kid and I I've met him a
couple of times super nice guy super
nice guy and I don't know what the [ __ ]
he needs to do to get back in and you
look at someone like stranger things you
see Winona Ryder I'm Matthew Modine you
said earlier until around I mean you see
guys get another chance you know you
look at that show with what's-his-name
from Cheers
Ted Danson Oh Ted's trying again you
know I know that Sebastian Maniscalco is
pilot got paid didn't know I didn't get
picked up but they had um what's that
dude's name Tony Danza oh it is dad you
know so you seek older guys from the 80s
but then Ralph Macchio it's like what
have you been doing as a child star I
have a question for you because Ken
because I always see people who do
really really stellar in one movie and I
had a day they play a very memorable
role and then they do something else and
they just are so lackluster like they
were only really good for that role so a
nice for example is Jennifer Hudson in
Dreamgirls was it oh it isn't I mean she
won an Oscar spectacular
she was emotional it was just a perfect
role for her and you see her in anything
else and it's just not compelling right
it's almost awkward to watch her and she
was in Sex in the City I think or like
she had a small role there or something
else where I was just like wow this just
isn't doesn't feel right Oscar like the
lay man you get out like Hilary Swank
nothing since but see Hilary sweet to me
poor legit has acting chops stop stop we
watch you to learn the core
she was also do you guys know what the
Korres Earth movie right we're like
drills yeah core I love disaster movie
yeah
the core is the best one we well he
makes me watch maker watch like every
three I'm gonna tell you the premise
everybody it's basically the center of
the earth the core stops rotating that
the metal what you call it the outer
it's the core core and the core is you
know mean hot liquid yes yes no iron he
was spinning that things stop spinning
and so they create a spaceship to go to
the center of the earth to plant bombs
that's get kick-started yeah it's so
believable it's really just our place
here that one reality so many big actors
in that movie swank Stanley Tucci Delroy
Lindo Lindo Oh them what's his name uh
Harvey Dent
Oh Harvey Dent let's call him Harvey
Harvey Dent in it Harvey Dent
yeah but yeah that movie is so bad but
so good I love although those volcano is
a good one every scene that one oh I
love that was a really good movie I love
it it's one of my favorites I love deep
impact the bad jet pack is good a bomb
like 2012 or what is it 2004 for mm you
know the one where they know that's a
good one too much tomorrow never done
James Bond movie tomorrow who does know
what what is that [ __ ] movie called
yeah he owns every single he is a
disaster man I I let me see something
right now the worse the better for him
oh if I could just be in one disaster
movie that's your career a thing that
like there I can just end it
it's like when I saw Christian Slater do
a Star Trek movie he had one line they
just left or you see um you know people
do cameos in a star I would love that
also but a disaster movie where I'm
running
like a landslide or I'm like being
engulfed in some sort of volcanic flame
or if I'm like you're meteors are
striking me in the skull oh I'm just
trying to climb under a car and I start
crying I would I would die to have a
roll like that
yeah I love disaster movies it's my
favorite and there's always one in every
disaster they have like prototypes or
stereotypes so there's always like a
politician who doesn't agree yeah I
don't believe in global and the whole
movie and then later he like learns yeah
yeah he has a change of heart I love
that outbreak is outbreak considered a
disaster modes a virus one right it's my
favorite all-time Donald Sutherland oh
by the way uh Harvey Dent
Aaron Eckhart Aaron Eckhart yeah he's
the best mommy should have known that I
love his face good and then he made a
great movie his best movie I
Frankenstein no and I'm telling you
right now I want consent in terms of bad
movies is pretty good I love bad movies
man
[Music]